if you didn't happen to snag an invite
to Prince Harry and Megan Merkel's royal
wedding this past May you're in luck
now you can relive the wedding magic
complete with commentary from the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex themselves the
couple who is currently in the middle of
their royal tour in Australia Fiji Tonga
and New Zealand share audio recordings
in a new exhibition on their royal
wedding
highlighting the special moments from
their big day and the days leading up to
it
Megan's stunning Givenchy gown and veil
are on display at Windsor Castle for the
exhibition alongside an identical
replica of Prince Harry's uniform also
on display the bridesmaid and pageboy
outfit that Princess Charlotte and
Prince George wore in one recording
megan recalls going with Prince Harry to
Buckingham Palace to meet with his
grandmother queen elizabeth ii to select
a tiara to complete her bridal ensemble
she says quote when it came to the tiara
on the day I was very fortunate to be
able to choose this gorgeous Art Deco
style bandeau tiara Harry and I had gone
to Buckingham Palace to meet with Her
Majesty the Queen to select one of the
options that were there which was an
incredibly surreal day as you can
imagine
Megan notes that the sparkling tiara
quickly quote stood out to her and
Prince Harry can be heard joking quote I
shouldn't have really been there Megan
also opens up about her wedding dress
saying it was quote very important for
her to have a female designer who was
British because she quote wanted to
embrace my new home in that way
in June roll expert Katie Nicol dish DT
about the hefty price tag for her
wedding gown
I was certainly told that she was
wanting to to make her own contribution
to the wedding and wanted to pay for the
wedding dress herself but the guidance
that I have from the palace is that they
paid for all of the major parts of the
wedding and of course a major part of
any wedding includes the dress so it may
be that make them contributed but
certainly some of the cost for either of
those wedding dresses or perhaps both of
those wedding dresses I believe was also
picked up by the palace
the veil and rest took 3900 hours to
complete and required 50 people to make
it part of the discussions around the
veil what we were going to do would it
be a lace edge or a border and I said
wouldn't it be amazing if we took the 53
countries of the Commonwealth and
embroidered a flower and some flora and
fauna from each one of those and that
they would go up the aisle that journey
up they are with you it's just a
wonderful embracing aspect of the whole
ceremony the exhibition is currently on
display in the castles grand reception
room where Queen Elizabeth hosted the
couple's wedding reception after their
nuptials back in May
[Music]